good morning thanks thanks for coming
this morning I'm here to talk about
typescript type system
I came to type scripting kind of a
roundabout way I've been looking for a
language I could use to do statically
type of functional programming language
programming and I've been looking at F
sharp and reason ml and I found myself
kind of surprised to land on typescript
I work at a consultancy called atomic
object and we do a lot of different
kinds of work we're a product
development consultancy we do mobile
desktop web API work and I wanted a
language that would work across the
broad spectrum of projects that we do
both on the technical side but also on
the non-technical side in particularly I
wanted something that would be
comfortable for a lot of different
clients a lot of different stakeholders
so typescript it's kind of a lot of
different things first and foremost it's
a language it's a strict superset of
JavaScript adds a it adds a type system
to to JavaScript giving it its name it's
also very configurable you can target
many different use cases and vary in
different strictness levels we use
typescript at the maximum strictness
level so the way that we use typescript
not all javascript is valid typescript
but in other other settings that is the
case it's an NPM package and that NPM
package includes a compiler so compiles
typescript into JavaScript and you can
target whatever level of browser
compatibility you want so with
typescript you don't actually need to
use babel at all it's also a language
server that provides IDE like
capabilities for a broad set of text
editors so instead of them in Emacs and
a demand vs code each needing to
implement their own IDE like features
for typescript all those editors can get
autocomplete and type checking within
the editor by using the capabilities
built right into the NPM package and
it's an open source project from
Microsoft so thanks to all the people
that are behind it but today we're gonna
focus just on what I find to be the most
interesting exciting part of typescript
the types of system it's really the
thing that when I took a look at it I
realized wow there's a lot of really
cool stuff here so that's what we're
focusing on today really everything in
this talk is about what happens before
you execute a single line of your code
it's it's just about things that are
happening in your text editor as you
type or within the compiler at when it
compiles you're you're Pro
so let's let's move on so a little bit
about what is a static type system it's
a it's a logic system that derives
constraints from looking at code
structures and reasons about them
systematically to find inconsistencies
it's not a lot of other things so it's
not about memory layout or code
optimization a compiler can use
information from the type system in
order to generate more efficient code
but the type system itself doesn't
necessarily imply that it's not a
runtime metadata facility just because
the compiler knows something about your
code doesn't mean it needs to make that
programmatically available to you and
it's also not necessarily about data
validation and in particular type script
doesn't do any of these things it's a
gradual type system that's really there
to help find bugs in your JavaScript
code and the thing that got me really
excited about typescript is that I
wanted something that would allow me to
take a type first approach to doing
software development which i think is
summed up nicely by this tweet when
people say but most business logic bugs
aren't type errors I just want to show
them how to make bugs into type errors
and this for me was kind of the key AHA
after coming from a decade of use of
doing development and dynamically type
programming languages if we can take the
invariance and the constraints about our
program that we have in our heads at the
time that we're designing it and hoist
them into the type system we can take
what might be a production issue at 2:00
in the morning and turn it into a red
squiggly in our text editor we can also
be a great tool for reteaching our
future selves about what we had in mind
and how we were reasoning about the
system at the time that we built it and
when you do this a lot of really
interesting things that you don't
necessarily expect to be type errors can
be caught as type errors we have in one
of our react app Lakai shion's we've
made the type system aware of all of the
different translations that that our
application supports and if we have a
typo and a tag for a translation it'll
point that out to us or if we fail to
provide all of the interpolation
variables that translation expects it'll
also give us red squiggly it's
statically impossible for us to have a
translation error in this program so we
don't have to click through our
application and leave the email address
blank only to find out that our Spanish
translation is missing the error message
when you fail to provide an email
address another another example that
really for me open my eyes toward the
the value that a static type system can
provide
is the ability to hoist permissions into
the type system so if we create a type
to represent the permission to do a
dangerous activity such as editing a
blog post we can make a value of that
type an argument to you to a routine
that go is going to go and perform that
dangerous activity and then that way we
can statically prove that all code paths
that are going to be updating blog posts
on the website have first been checked
for permission according to the user so
today I want to focus on three main
aspects of type scripts type system that
let us do this this sort of thing one is
a little bit of an overview of how it's
a structural type system in that a
nominal type system and what that means
the second is we'll take a look at how
it thinks about types as sets and how
that can help us model problems model
constraints into the end of the type
system and we'll also take a look at how
it gives us a language for deriving one
type from another so first and foremost
type script is mostly just the
JavaScript that you're used to day in
and day out if you're ever wondering
what type strip is going to do at
runtime it is literally going to do
exactly what the JavaScript equivalent
in your in your source file says it's
going to do but we can also define types
and we can use this colon suffix syntax
to associate a type with a variable type
scoped also does type inference so we
don't necessarily need to do so but
we'll do so for the most part going
forward
typescript has all of the same built-in
types that you'd expect of a of a C like
language we've got boolean's and strings
and numbers we can add square brackets
at the end of a type to denote an array
we can use a curly brace style object
literal type syntax to denote an object
type in this case objects with X&Y that
are both numbers we can surround types
with square brackets to denote temple
types so in this case pairs of boolean's
and strings and we can also have types
for functions so if we want to take a
function as an argument or return one we
can have static typing support with that
now we can also give names to these
types which pretty obviously important
and there are a couple different ways to
do so but we'll be using this syntax the
type keyword and one thing that's kind
of interesting about this is that it
looks a lot like assigning a constant
we're saying type point equals curly
brace X number Y number and the thing is
that this isn't just a syntactic
peculiarity this gets out at kind of
important concept in
how type scripts type system works
namely that the actual type is the stuff
in the curly braces and we're merely
associating a name with that type using
the type keyword and this kind of falls
out of the fact that typescript is a
structural type system so a lot of
mainstream statically typed languages
are nominally typed which means that the
identity of the type itself is really
important if you have two interfaces in
Java that both have the same methods on
them you can't use those things
interchangeably because there are
different interfaces even though they
have they require the same things of
values of those types typescript doesn't
care about that at all it just cares
about what constraints the type is in is
implying about the values for that are
in that type so I kind of think a good
metaphor for this is a nominal type is
like a secret Club that you need to be
invited into but a structural type is
like just a set of minimal requirements
that everybody needs to meet and as long
as you meet those requirements you can
you can Walter it in so one way to kind
of think about this and this is for me
is a useful metaphor for reasoning about
the type system is that it's kind of a
language for describing a predicate that
must be true of all values that are
going to be used in that that point in
the in your code so the type point has
requires an x and a y that are both
number we can kind of imagine this as
being described as describing the set of
all values that are objects that are not
null that have an x and y property that
are both numbers since we use typescript
at the maximum strictness setting no
pointer exceptions are not something
that are possible by default we have to
opt into that this has some other
implications as well so if we have
another type named point and this could
come from anywhere it could be from a
third-party library doesn't have to have
anything to do with our original point
type because of the fact that name point
also requires there to be an x and y
that are both number it's it has natural
structural overlap with our original
point type and because typescript
doesn't care about the identity of the
types it cares about the constraints
that are implied name point naturally is
a subtype of our point type anywhere we
have a name point we can we can use it
as a point so the set of points includes
things that just have an X and a Y but
it also includes all of our name points
and anything else that that's compatible
these these tests that the types imply
about our our values are the
minimum types that are necessary to
ensure compatibility they don't say
anything about having extra things along
for the ride especially with object
types other interesting things pop out
of this as well so if we have another
type called named that are things that
have a type name then we also see that
name point naturally is a subtype of
both of those things it's kind of the
intersection of both of these two types
all named points can be used anywhere a
name is expected it's a they can also be
used anywhere that a point is expected
and this this is kind of for me
something that was really great about
typescript coming from dynamic languages
one of the things I like about dynamic
languages is that if I write a function
any value that's compatible with the
code within that function can be passed
to it in typescript we can just make
make those requirements explicit and
it'll let us pass in any value that it
can prove is compatible and this makes
structural typing feel really light it's
a really kind of nice balance of the
flexibility that we're used to in a
dynamically typed language with the
safety and tooling support that we can
get from a statically typed language and
this is great
but it's not what we need to really be
able to model the invariants about our
domain into the type system itself we
need more powerful ways of doing things
with the type system so let's take a
look at a motivating example from F
sharp there that this feature called
some types and this is built into a lot
of different statically typed functional
programming languages let's say we want
to write a program that deals with
shapes and there are a finite number of
shapes that we want to be able to
support so we might define our shape
type to be either a square that has a
size that's an integer or a rectangle
with a width and a height we can then
define algorithms on that type for
example a routine to calculate the area
that can check which of the the type of
shape we're dealing with and then
calculate the area accordingly now
there's actually not a lot that can go
wrong with this definition of shape it's
statically typed we can't pass a non
shape to a function that it requires a
shape the this pattern matching syntax
the match keyword let forces us to kind
of prove which type of shape we're
dealing with before we can we can use it
sub properties so we can't access the
size of a rectangle or the width and a
height of a square because those
those aren't valid for those those
particular variations within the shape
type it also knows that there are
exactly two types of shape and it's
proving for us that our area function is
dealing with all of them if we add
circle to our shape type down the road
then F sharp will point out to us that
our area function is no longer returning
values for all of the different options
so let's take a look at how this maps
into typescript well it doesn't some
types aren't a feature of typescript but
there are a number of different features
of the type system that we can mix and
match in powerful ways to get something
that's pretty close to what what f sharp
can do for us now in particular we have
some type level operations that let us
combine individual types into larger
compound types there's a feature of the
language called control flow based type
analysis where typescript understands
the implications about control flow
constructs like if statements and switch
statements about the types that they're
dealing with and literal types which let
us go more granular than the built in
boolean and string and number types that
are that we're used to and deal with
things in a more granular wave so if we
take another look back at our two types
point and named our name point type
happened to fall at the intersection of
those things because we define them just
defined it just so that it would it
would lie there but if we wanted to
construct a type that was guaranteed to
always be the intersection of those two
types that might be a useful operation
and we can do that on typescript using
the ampersand operator which intersects
two types and so we could alternatively
define our name point type by
intersecting the points the the types
point and named and if we do so we
already get some nice properties from
this if we change the definition of
point or change the definition of named
those changes will flow through our name
point type and typescript will point out
to us all the places in our code where
our name point type is not compatible so
this kind of has its own imaginary
predicate functioned constraining the
values that that type can take on for
some X to be a name point it has to
satisfy the requirements of both the
point type and the name type and for me
this is a useful mnemonic for thinking
about why intersection is the ampersand
because it's kind of adding together all
of the requirements of both both types
and so with this we can access X and a
name on our name point this
we could be four but other things won't
be valid now you might you might ask
yourself well if we can intersect types
together it could be also union types
together and sure enough we can do that
as well with the pipe operator we can
construct a type that's allowed to be
any value that's of one type or another
type so if we Union together the number
and string types both one and foooor
valid values of that type boolean czar
not and typescript kind of has an
internal understanding that whatever
we're going to use there has to be
either a number or a string that's
that's how I like to think about it at
least so you might ask yourself well
okay why why would I want two or types
together and the reason is because it
mat meshes really well with this control
flow based type analysis that typescript
does so this is this is about
understanding what your if statements
are proving about the types that they're
dealing with so if we have a constant
that's a type number Union with string
type script won't let us multiply that
constant by two because it could be a
string and we can't multiply strings by
two but it could be a number and it's
sure enough it's valid to multiply
numbers in order to do so though we
first need to prove to typescript that
we're dealing with a number or not a
string and we can do this using the the
standard built-in JavaScript control
flow constructs that we use everyday so
if we use the typeof operator to prove
that X is a number control flow based
type analysis we'll will cast the the
constant into the type number
eliminating the possibility of being a
string within the then Clause of that if
statement and then the else Clause of
that if statement it will eliminate the
number of possibility because we've
disproven it and it will let us treat
that constant as a string so if we
wanted to find a function double that's
going to take it a number or string and
double it then within this if we if we
were to hover over the X in the the if
statement at that point it's a number or
a string but but when we go to return
two times X typescript understands that
it can only be a number in that case and
similarly in the else clause it knows
that X is a string and so we have to
treat it accordingly so we can start to
see that there's some overlap between
these two features and the the
capabilities of the the some types that
we saw in F sharp
so let's take a look at how close we can
get to this with what we've seen so far
we could define a type square that has a
size that's a number and a rectangle
that has a width and a height and then
we can Union those two types together
one thing that's kind of interesting
about this is that the types square and
rectangle are just standalone
independent types that we can use
however we want and we can assemble
those together with a union operator to
construct a larger compound type that
could be either of those things and we
can define our area function but we
start to run into some problems here
because we don't actually have a good
way of distinguishing between whether or
not we have a square or a rectangle we
can do so by using the built in in
operator to test whether or not size as
a property but it's kind of not very
savory to prove that we have a square by
testing for some property that Square
happens to have so let's see can we do
better and if we look at the the example
from F sharp we have this kind of nice
declarative way of saying if we're
dealing with the square let us treat it
as such and if we're dealing with a
rectangle let us let us do so
accordingly so the solution to this in
typescript is to take a closer look at
those built-in types that we saw at the
beginning boolean string and number
these types are sets of values boolean's
can be true or false strings can be foo
or bar and in a lot of c-like languages
the most granular you can get is boolean
or string or a number we can define a
variable or a parameter to be a boolean
but we have no control over whether it's
true or false we can we can define
something to be a string but we have no
control over which string statically at
least which string that can take on but
in typescript every literal data
structure can also be used as a type and
when we do so it denotes a type
containing just that one runtime value
so if we wanted to we could union
together the types true and false to
denote a new type my boolean that could
either be true or false and because of
the structural compatibility properties
typescript this is directly equivalent
to the built-in boolean type and we can
use the two interchangeably or we could
union together the types literal string
okay with literal string error denoting
a type that could be one of those two
strings but no other string would be
allowed in that case and this doesn't
just apply to the atomic types but we
can also apply it to compound types so
we if we wanted a result to not be a
string but to be an object
we can we can Union together objects
that have a status okay and objects with
a status error now this this does not
denote exactly two possible values for a
result because the compatibility
constraints imply that we only care
about status so our result could have
additional fields but if we're treating
as a stet as a result in this case we
won't be able to access those but if we
wanted to do so we're not actually
limited to just literal datatypes here
we can use any type that we want so if
we wanted to denote to have just one
successful case but have an infinite
family of all the things that could
possibly go wrong we could add a reason
property that's a string and then now we
we are always guaranteed that our
failure case will have a status of error
but the reason can be any description
that's appropriate and this is actually
the the solution to doing some types in
typescript often called discriminated
unions is to add a property common to
all of the types that we're unioning
together but to use literal literal
types to note very specific values that
that the type system can understand and
use for us so we'll add a kind property
to square that's guaranteed to be the
string square and a kind of property to
rectangle that can only be the string
rectangle and then with this we're
actually about as close as we can get in
JavaScript or in typescript to the some
types that we saw in F sharp so given
the shape s if we switch on the kind of
S and prove that it's the string square
then typescript will automatically
convert s to a square for us with in
that case clause and do the
multiplication within the rectangle case
we can multiply the width and the height
and this actually has a lot of the
safety guarantees that are in the F
sharp example if not the syntactic
elegance we we know that we're getting a
shape so typescript will ensure for us
that anything pass to it is compatible
with the shape definition we won't be
able to access the size of a rectangle
or the width and the height of a square
because those properties aren't
appropriate aren't present and also
typescript will prove for us it'll do
exhaustive miss checking so if we add
circle to our shape type down the road
then this definition is no longer
guaranteed to return a number and so
typescript will point out to us that
we're missing a case and we can come
back and add it to deal with our circle
shape and then
for me is the kind of cool and exciting
part of typescript is that there's a lot
of little capabilities within the type
system that we can combine in powerful
ways to model the constraints and
variants that we that we know it to be
true about our business domain or our or
our abstractions and bring them into the
type system so this is this is great
actually some types are kind of
bread-and-butter way of making invalid
states and representable in our
applications we use them all the time a
lot of what we do is is based on
unioning and intersecting types together
but sometimes we need to be able to
express more complex relationships
between types and one the way that we
can do that in typescript is using
generics using a similar seat the same
similar syntax to what you'd see in
c-sharp or java so we can add angle
brackets to a type definition to make to
denote a generic type which you can kind
of think of as a function that takes
types as inputs and produces types as
outputs so if we wanted to create a
stack data structure of some underlying
type T we could then instantiate that
for some some type that we have if we
wanted to have a stack of animals lying
around then we could we could do so and
if we if we grab the top the the top
thing off of our stack data structure
type script we'll have preserved for us
that which type of stack we're dealing
with and let us let us use that variable
accordingly and this is something we can
do in any language with generics we can
take some opaque type T that we don't
really know anything about and wrap it
up in some structure and this is why
generics are used for collections and
pretty much every language but what if
we want to do something a little bit
more sophisticated than what's built
into what's then merely
a creating structure around an existing
type what if for example we want to be
able to take some arbitrary object type
as an input and then produce a new type
that has the same structure except every
single property has been made optional
using this question mark syntax and type
script so one reason we might want to do
this is to have a generic update
function that takes some object as an
argument in a subset of its properties
that we wish to update and give us back
a new instance of that type with those
properties updated I'd like to be able
to do so without accidentally updating
the title of a user or a first name of a
blog post in order
to do that we need to communicate to the
type system that there's a relationship
between the type of the first argument
to update in the type of the second
target argument namely whatever we pass
in for the first argument we want some
subset of those properties used in the
the second argument so what we need is a
little function a little program that
can pull apart the first the type that
we're using for the first argument and
build back up a new type where every
every part of it has been made optional
so we need ways of actually manipulating
types the way that we that we manipulate
data and a lot of statically typed
functional languages there's a phrase
for this type level programming we can
kind of think of there being two
different levels of programming to a
statically typed language with a
powerful type system one is the value
level which is what we're used to it's
data flowing through our system
variables that sort of a thing but we
can also think of programming in terms
of types as well to allow us to do these
sort of derivations of types from other
types to communicate more more powerful
and variants about about our domain so
let's start let's take a look at how we
can do some type level programming in
typescript and how that maps to the
concepts that we're used to on a regular
basis so we've already seen the the
analog to constants and typescript we
can use the type keyword to associate a
name with a type the same way we can use
the Const keyword to associate a name
with a value now because typescript is
structural and it doesn't care about the
identity of types it only compares and
cares about the constraints that those
types imply we can actually substitute
anywhere we see the name of a type we
can actually substitute it for the the
underlying structure of that type those
two definitions of p1 are effectively
equivalent there are some differences
and how error messages get reported but
they constrain the values of your your
program and the realm of value types in
the same way and this notion of
substitutability is really important
it's kind of foundational a foundational
principle of how to reason about
functional programs pure functional
programs and we can actually think about
how the type system executes and
evaluates our our generic types and
typescript the same way that we think
about how a functional program executes
by repeated repeated substitution of
of lambdas so let's look at a simple
example of that if we take another look
at our name point type we see that we
have a name we have our name type and
our point type we can substitute those
names for the underlying type
definitions and so we have objects of
type that have a name that's a string
intersected with objects that have an X
or Y that are a number now the
intersection operator is built right in
a type script but it has the effect of
kind of unioning together all of the
properties of those object types to
produce for us our original definition
of main point that had a name that's a
string and x and a y that are both a
number and so we can kind of see we can
reason about how typescript will
repeatedly expand these types to produce
an output structure for us and this is
kind of a general way we can think about
what it's doing with our types within
the type system and this is all none of
this is running at runtime this is
entirely running within your type
checker within the compiler generics
also map in a really direct way to
function so we could create an identity
function that takes a value X and
returns it we could create an identity
type that takes a type t and returns it
we could create a function that takes an
X and a Y and returns a pair of x and y
we could create a type pair that takes
types tnu and returns the tupple type of
those two things so a lot of the things
that we're used to thinking about in
terms of functional programming in the
value realm map into the type system as
well so we start to see that there is a
way we can reason about solving this
sort of problem now partial is actually
built right into two types script it's
in the standard library but it's just
using more fundamental things that are
built into the type system and so we can
actually take a closer look at how this
actually would execute so if we take a
look at the problem at a high level we
can kind of see that this has a similar
shape to it something we do every day
namely we need to map over the
properties of our object types to
produce new corresponding properties in
a resulting type and so the way that we
that we can do this in typescript
is is with this type definition which
I'll unpack in a minute so partial is a
generic type that takes some input type
T and then uses this syntax to expand to
you the result type that we want so
let's kind of substitute through this
and see how it executes so let's start
by replacing T with our the type point
that we want to deal with
this is directly equivalent to the curly
brace syntax we saw a moment ago but it
just gets a little messy so you can
imagine curly brace XY number here if
you wanted to but we'll just stick with
plain now if we look at this at a high
level we can kind of see that
syntactically this looks like a lot like
list comprehensions in Python except
this is more at like an object type
comprehension we're saying for each K
that's a key of our type point then
let's produce an let's produce a
property in the output type that's made
optional by the question mark at the end
of the first line and whose
corresponding type is computed on the
second line by sub scripting point with
K so there are three things going on
here that are being combined together
into a little function to produce the
resulting type kiyah point is built-in
it takes an object type and returns a
list of all of the known properties of
that type the over up the overall syntax
is called a mapped type and type script
will just iterate through whatever
whatever individual entries are in the
list returned by Kiev and produce the
corresponding property and the object
type for us and then this subscript
syntax point subscript K works the same
way in the type system that it does in
regular JavaScript so namely it in the
value level we can subscript an object
with a string to get the value
associated with that string and the
object we can subscript an object type
in the type system with the literal
string type to get the corresponding
type of that property in the object type
so we'll start by substituting kea point
with with its result which is the string
literal X Union and with this the string
literal Y so Union types within the type
system also serve double duty as sort of
a list now the overall comprehension
syntax understands that and so it will
iterate through that list and let K take
on each individual entry within that
Union expanding for us into an object
type that has X that's optional and Y
that's optional and where the individual
values of K have been substituted into
our point subscript now because point
has the type number for the X property
and also has the type number for the Y
property those substitute out to be the
number type giving us
the result that we were hoping for
originally so we've kind of seen that
there's a built-in idea of mapping over
object properties to produce a
corresponding object type there's a key
of operator to give us the list of
properties built into an object type we
can use the subscript syntax to get a
type corresponding to a specific
property of an object all things that we
need to be able to manipulate in more
sophisticated ways are object types to
direct him to do more sophisticated
derivations of new types a couple of
things to work worth noting we're used
to using if statements all the time in
our value level code there's actually a
direct correspondence and type script
type system in the type system within
the the type checker in your text editor
you can actually test one type for
compatibility with another type and then
make decisions about what to do based
off of that we've also already seen that
that recursion is built-in and we can do
mutual recursion and that sort of a
thing and this for me it was like when I
started to see this in typescript I was
like wow there is a built-in functional
language built right into the type
system and it's a type system for
JavaScript one of the were deists and
most practical languages on the planet
so a lot of this stuff isn't stuff that
we use everyday when we're developing
developing in typescript it's it is a
very powerful language I don't think
it's quite turning complete I'm not sure
but everything's based on sub structural
recursion so as far as I know everything
always terminates I've certainly never
kicked the type system in an infinite
loop but this this isn't the normal
thing that we're doing day in and day
out for me this is really more of a sign
that there's a lot of depth within the
type system that can really reward
mastery the time that I've spent
learning about some of the more advanced
or niche features in type scripts type
system have really paid off in my
ability to do to do powerful things rule
out bugs that otherwise pop up at
runtime make translation systems that
statically rule out references to two
rules that are incorrect and and this
for me was a really interesting fun
exercise seeing this this marriage of
one of the most practical
languages on the planet JavaScript with
this cool powerful elegant type system
that at least if if nothing else papers
over a lot of the words that are that
are built into that and it's led to a
better development experience higher
quality products better outcomes for our
customers and I've really enjoyed it so
there we go thank you very much
I think I've got some time for questions
so the first question is does structural
typing eliminate certain forms of
hoisting business logic into the type
system so with anomaly type system one
thing that's nice about it is you can it
does deny implicit conversion between
types that you don't want to be
implicitly converted so with a
structural type system that doesn't
happen by default but there are tricks
that we can do to kind of convert a type
into and sort of ad-hoc nominal types so
one of the things that we can we'll do
is we'll add virtual properties to a
type that force an inconsistency with
other similar types and that way we can
have the the nominal typing property in
the places where we want it but without
having the the lack of flexibility that
normally comes with it one way that we
do one way that we use this is to
support units so we can introduce type
incompatibilities between different
forms of numbers by associating with
that with them some virtual properties
in the type system so that we it
disallows mixing for example inches and
gallons so let's see what are your least
favorite parts of typescript what are
the agreed-upon weaknesses of the
language my least favorite parts of
typescript are all JavaScript so in is
because typescript is based on the
JavaScript ecosystem we're mostly using
third-party NPM packages and those by
and large don't have well formulated
types associated with them so there's a
big open source project to create types
for a lot of popular open source
JavaScript libraries but in a lot of
cases those types don't actually
correctly capture the semantics of the
JavaScript library itself so there can
be a fair amount of pain and using
third-party JavaScript libraries and
having good typescript support for those
which can be a little bit frustrating
but at the same time it's usually one of
the thing because typescript is a
gradual type system you don't actually
have to use strong like static typing
really granular static typing everywhere
you can actually just say this part of
the code tree
as JavaScript and don't try to check
anything about it so what we'll often do
in those cases is we'll wrap a pure
JavaScript library or a poorly typed
JavaScript library with a with an API
where we provide types ourselves and we
have a little bit of untyped code within
a well-defined statically typed
interface and that that helps alleviate
the issue do folks use typescript to
implement monads so there isn't
typescript has this really kind of
strict rule they don't introduce any
runtime code that you didn't write
yourself and monads aren't a feature of
JavaScript so they're also not a few
feature of typescript I think you can
get part of the way there I mean there's
async await and promises which I think
are a monad I don't know if you can do
some clever hacks to do something with
that and I've also seen people use kind
of object fluent object syntax where you
repeatedly chained method calls on an
object with lambdas to kind of get
somewhere in the vicinity but no that's
not built-in and there are definitely
some cases where we're using like an
either result type where we really wish
we had a monadic syntax but I haven't
seen that myself
I haven't also really looked at it how
do you test types move I love this
question this is great
so we found we found an NPM package
called Taipings tester or Taipings
checker where you can create a
typescript file where you where you
create a bunch of individual expressions
where you define say a constant of some
type in a signup variable to it and some
of those should type check and others
should not so there's a magic comment
you can add in those files to say expect
a type error on the next line so what we
can actually do is we can use that to
test drive our type first development
process before we test drive our value
level process so that that ends up being
pretty useful you can kind of just say
here a bunch of examples of things that
should type check here a bunch of
examples of things that should not type
check formulate the types for those get
that that test to pass now you have a
type definition that very very
accurately encodes exactly what you want
to be able to do with the value level
and then you have the help of that in
both writing your value level unit
and your your value level code so how
would the typescript handle intersecting
types with members named the same but
different fundamental types so it
I believe what happens there is they get
the example of having two objects that
both have an ID one of which is a number
and one of which is a string I think
that in the resulting type I'm not sure
about this but I think in the resulting
type the ID property would be something
that's both a number and a string which
is an impossible type so it would it
would intersect those together for you
but you'd have a really hard time
providing a value that that meets that
requirement all right how do you how do
those type script handle function
composition and higher-order functions
it handles those quite well so I didn't
really get into it but you can you can
define generic functions that's really
probably one of the most common ways we
do some of the things that that I showed
here today and with that you can you can
create generic higher-order functions
and it works quite well similar to a lot
of other statically typed functional
languages and I think that'll be it
thank you very much
[Applause]